Since casting is such an integral part of
any film, directors will typically hold auditions
for key roles.
This means that even some of the biggest stars
in the industry have to try out before they
sign on for a project – regardless of how
talented they are.
Sometimes, these screen tests don’t always
go so well.
It doesn’t matter if the thespian in question
has won numerous awards throughout their career;
there’s always a chance they’re just not
the best fit for a certain role.
And they find that hard the hard way.
Here are 10 talented actors with the scariest
audition stories.
If you like what you see, be sure to subscribe
to our channel and give us a thumbs up!
Eddie Redmayne
Eddie Redmayne has received an Oscar for playing
Steven Hawking and is now a part of J.K.
Rowling’s famed wizarding world, but there
is one thing we know he can’t do: be a villain
in a Star Wars film.
Redmayne was one of the actors who read for
Kylo Ren during pre-production on The Force
Awakens, and it’s safe to say he bombed
his audition.
Due to the secrecy of the project, Redmayne
was reciting lines from other movies and only
knew his would-be character was a bad guy.
He started doing a poor Darth Vader impression
and spoke in a funny voice, which didn’t
win over the casting directors.
At least he has Newt Scamander.
Aaron Paul
The Breaking Bad star had a minor role in
J.J. Abrams’ Mission: Impossible 3, so it’s
no surprise he met with the filmmaker again
while Abrams was working on Cloverfield.
When Paul arrived for the audition, Abrams
had the actor tell a story of a cool card
trick he performed during M:I 3, which caused
Paul to lose his train of thought.
Instead of delivering a three-page monologue
he memorized, Paul had to stop in the middle
of it and apologize.
All Abrams said was ‘That’s OK.
Thanks for coming in.’ and Paul left without
the part.
But shortly after he became Jesse Pinkman,
so it all worked out.
Blake Lively
Lively looked to make movies at a very young
age, trying out for the hit comedy Mrs. Doubtfire
when she was just 5-years old.
Blake’s mom didn’t want her daughter to
get star struck by Robin Williams, so she
told Blake that she’d be reading with the
comedian’s twin brother.
When Lively walked in, the filmmakers introduced
her to the one and only Robin Williams, and
Blake’s response was, “You’re not his
twin?”
You can probably guess how things went after
that.
When Blake came out of the room, she told
mom that Williams had morning breath and moved
on.
Now that Lively is a successful actress, she
can laugh about that mishap.
Chris Evans
These days, people are in awe to meet Captain
America, but prior to the actor’s Marvel
days, it was the other way around.
Evans met with Ben Affleck to audition for
the Boston legend’s directorial debut, Gone
Baby Gone.
Upon arriving, Evans became nervous and asked
Affleck if the parking spot he chose was OK.
After an awkward conversation about parking
meters ensued, Evans was mortified and couldn’t
wait to leave the room.
He was so upset that he gave Affleck one-word
answers to any question asked and kept rocking
in the chair he was sitting in.
Now that they’re both established superheroes,
maybe Affleck and Evans can work together
one day.
Chris Pine
Chris Pine made a name for himself as the
new Captain Kirk in the rebooted Star Trek
series, but he could have had a role in a
different 2009 sci-fi blockbuster.
Pine was in the running for James Cameron’s
Avatar, but his audition went horribly.
Recalling the experience, Pine mentioned that
he went into the room not believing in himself
as he tried to picture Cameron’s ambitious
vision for the film.
He stopped halfway through his reading, and
the casting director was either smiling or
laughing at him.
Neither one would be ideal, and the role of
Jake Sully eventually went to Sam Worthington.
Pine has led three successful Star Trek movies,
so it’s clear he’s got talent.
Jake Gyllenhaal
Jake Gyllenhaal has emerged as a chameleon
actor capable of completing transforming himself
for a role, but he’s steered clear of big-budget
productions.
Maybe his awful experience auditioning for
Lord of the Rings played a role in that.
Gyllenhaal read for Frodo, but nobody told
the actor that the character had an English
accent.
Gyllenhaal recited his lines in an American
accent, which didn’t please Peter Jackson.
The director told Gyllenhaal to fire his agents
and felt it was one of the worst auditions
he’d seen.
This is why it’s always best to prepare
as much as possible, a lesson Gyllenhaal seems
to have learned.
Leonardo DiCaprio
Leo has played everything from a sleazy stockbroker
to a dream thief to a vicious slave owner
in his career, so there’s very little he
can’t do.
Director Baz Luhrmann discovered one limitation
of DiCaprio while casting Moulin Rouge: singing.
Leo admitted he feels he has a horrible singing
voice, but tried out for the musical anyway.
Luhrmann played piano while DiCaprio sang
a tune, and when the Oscar winner reached
a high note, Luhrmann stopped and said, “I
don’t know if this conversation should continue.”
Leo has acted in numerous genres, but this
is one he probably won’t audition for again.
Some people just aren’t cut out for singing.
Bradley Cooper
Bradley Cooper quickly rose to the top of
the A-list thanks to a trio of Oscar nominated
performances that made him an awards season
mainstay, but before he became a critical
darling, his career could have taken a different
trajectory.
Cooper was one of the names considered for
2011’s Green Lantern, but the actor didn’t
really take his audition seriously.
His screen test amounted to doing an impersonation
of Christian Bale’s gravely voiced Batman,
when the casting people wanted him to just
talk normally.
Cooper didn’t get the role, and that turned
out to be a bullet dodged.
Now, we’re just wondering when he’ll win
his Academy Award instead of how he’ll recover
from a flop.
Daniel Radcliffe
You know the old saying, “if you don’t
have anything nice to say, don’t say it?”
Even a kind-hearted hero like Harry Potter
forgets that sometimes.
While in an audition, Daniel Radcliffe was
gossiping about somebody when another person
came walking in the room.
Radcliffe continued his story and when he
finished, he came to the sobering realization
that the person he was talking about was a
good friend of who Radcliffe had to audition
for.
We don’t know which movie this was, but
it’s safe to say it’s not a project on
the actor’s IMDb page.
Talk about an awkward situation.
Channing Tatum
Channing Tatum has gone from a pretty boy
to a go-to actor who has worked with respected
auteurs like Steven Soderbergh, Quentin Tarantino,
and the Coen brothers, but he had a rocky
journey to the top.
Earlier in his career, Tatum auditioned for
a role in Fast and Furious: Tokyo Drift, but
he forgot the most important lesson: remember
your lines.
Yes.
Tatum could not remember the dialogue he was
supposed to say during the screen test and
ended up freaking out and sweating profusely.
He obviously didn’t get that part, but he
managed to turn things around down the road
and become a Hollywood leading man.
Chloe Grace-Moretz
The legendary Martin Scorsese is a director
every actor dreams of working with, and when
auditioning for him, there’s no limits to
what people will attempt to get in his favor.
When trying out for one of the lead roles
in Scorsese’s love letter to cinema Hugo,
Chloe Grace-Moretz rolled the dice and told
the filmmaker a little lie.
The Georgia-born actress told Marty that she
was British and tried to pass it off so she
could get the part.
Apparently, Chloe is good at fudging up the
truth, since Scorsese cast her in Hugo.
If he was impressed, Moretz did something
right.
Conclusion
Those are just some of the worst audition
stories from the A-listers.
Which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe so you can see more videos!